et la prise en charge de patients n'est
pas toujours évidente exemple sur l'île
de porquerolles situation situé pardon
large de toulon lille vit elle aussi au
rythme du confinement son village compte
actuellement près de 300 habitants qu'il
faut ravitailler mais aussi soigner
alors comment s'organise cette vie
insulaire les précisions d'isabelle
ferrières et pierre puis sa vie vers la
cité prisée des touristes en temps
normal les rues de porquerolles sont
aujourd'hui désertés
seuls les locaux sont présents en ces
temps de confinement entre 300 et 400
personnes vivent ici à l'année sur l'île
un seul médecin en cas d'urgence la
prise en charge peut être un peu plus
compliqué qu'ailleurs
j'ai eu hospitalisés qu'un seul patient
qui commençait donc à voir ce signe de
détresse respiratoire
ç'a permis justement de voir comment
bien juillet les rouages avec l'équipage
de pompiers avec le bateau taxi pour
évacuer la personne tout ça sur une île
il faut y penser
il peut y avoir des blocages si par
exemple le conducteur du bateau taxi
refusent
droit de retrait par rapport aux risques
de contagion
donc bon ça s'est bien passé un moment
compliqué également pour les commerçants
qui vit essentiellement du tourisme
la saison est censé avoir débuté depuis
trois semaines maintenant les rues et
les magasins de son fréquenté que par
les habitants de l'île
aucun visiteur pour le moment a pas de
manque de biens de première nécessité
mais parfois des difficultés
d'approvisionnement les centrales
d'approvisionnement elles ont du mal à
suivre
il ya énormément de rupture et que quand
vous avez des ruptures sur des produits
il faut vous débrouiller pour aller les
chercher ailleurs donc au niveau des
appros jour d'hui en temps normal j'ai
un camion de membres de mon groupe de
mon groupe en alimentaire
système u qui me livre devant le magasin
aujourd'hui je prends mon camion je vais
moi même faire mes courses pour pour ne
manquer de rien fait pour tout contrôler
c'est donc la vie tout entière de lille
qui est perturbé par l'épidémie de
coronavirus à prochain défi pour
porquerolles à la gestion du
déconfinement et du flux de touristes
qui pourrait débarquer prochainement sur
place